Fox News has obtained a list of
questions a special counsel Robert
Muller wants to ask President Trump if
he gets the chance about the Russia
investigation chief White House
correspondent John Roberts joins us live
from the north wall with a look at what
Muller wants to know good evening John
wreck it evening to you the leak of
these questions comes just as the
president's newly reconstituted legal
team had restarted negotiations with
Robert Muller about a possible interview
with the president I'm told that tonight
those negotiations are still on track
though many of the president's
supporters who say based on this line of
inquiry the president shouldn't get
anywhere near Robert Moeller in talks
with president Trump's legal team
special counsel robert muller revealed
52 questions he wants to ask the
president for topics Michael Flynn James
Comey Jeff Sessions and Donald Trump
Jr's meeting with a Russian attorney
among the things Muller wants to ask
what does president Trump know about
calls the general Flynn made with
Russian ambassador kis lyac in late
December 2016 and did people associated
with the president reach out to Flynn or
discuss Flynn seeking immunity or
possible pardon on Comey Muller wants to
know what was the purpose of the dinner
meeting the President had with Comey and
whether loyalty was discussed also why
President Trump tweeted that Comey
better hope there are no tapes on
sessions Comey wants to ask President
Trump about the Attorney General's
recusal and the president's reaction to
the appointment of a special counsel and
on Don junior come he wants to learn
what the president knew regarding the
June ninth Trump Tower meeting and when
he became aware of it also whether
President Trump was aware of outreach by
members or former members of his
campaign to Russia offering potential
assistance
Moeller specifically mentioned Paul
Manafort the White House which is often
weighed in on aspects of the Moller
investigation wanted no part of this
disclosure I would Fareed to the
president's outside personal attorneys
sources close to the investigation say
the questions were developed in early
March in consultations between Muller's
office and the president's outside legal
team President Trump today railed
against their disclosure twitting it was
disgraceful that the questions
concerning the Russian witch-hunt were
leaked to the media
no questions on collusion the White
House did weigh in today and a charge
from president Trump's former physician
dr. Harold Bornstein that in February of
last year his office was raided by then
director of oval office operations
keith's Schiller and Trump Organization
attorney Alan Garten Bornstein says they
took all of president Trump's medical
records that's how I feel
rape frightened the incident happened
two days after Bornstein told the New
York Times President Trump takes
propecia for hair loss the White House
today dismissed the notion of a raid as
a standard operating procedure for a new
president the White House medical unit
took possession of the president's
medical records on Iran the White House
was defending an unfortunate typo in a
statement last night that declared Iran
has a robust clandestine nuclear weapons
program the White House meant to say had
the typo that you referenced was noticed
immediately corrected and the president
today said he is close to an
announcement on his plan summit with
North Korean leader Kim jong-un also
weighing in on South Korean president
moon Jane's declaration the president
Trump should be awarded the Nobel Peace
Prize and I think it's probably going to
be announced over the next couple of
days location and date but I thought it
was very generous of president moon and
a development in the Michael Flynn case
today the court had requested a status
report on his sentencing for making
false statements today both flynn's
Counsel and the Special Counsel Robert
Muller's Office reported to the courts
that based on the status of the Moller
investigation now is not the time to be
talking about sentencing Michael Flynn
Brett
John Roberts live at the North Lawn John
thanks